[Music]
on this Saturday night gaza's hospitals
in crisis doctors and staff pushed to
the brink by Israeli bombardments it's
totally war zone and The Exodus of gazin
moving south trying to find
safety lest we forget I think it's good
to be here to thank you Reflections on
this Remembrance Day about those who
paid the ultimate price I'm just really
proud to be able to represent Canada
plus the pond in Hawaii that
mysteriously turned a bright shade of
Barbie
pink global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with Israel's war on Hamas as
tanks and troops move deeper into Gaza
and a warning some of the images in our
coverage are
disturbing St gaza's hospitals describe
chaos from near constant attacks as
Israeli forces close in at alifa
hospital gaza's largest it is
catastrophic that's according to Doctors
Without Borders it accuses Israel of
signing the death warrants of patients
there the UN has verified more than 250
attacks on healthc care facilities in
Gaza and the West Bank five hospitals it
says were hit in the last week Israel
denies that claiming it is targeting
terrorists who are choosing to fight
close to hospitals Israel has now
lowered its estimate of how many people
were killed in that surprise attack by
Hamas on October 7th it says it's about
1,200 people down from 1,400 since then
more than 11,000 people in Gaza have
been killed that's according to the
Hamas run Health ministry tonight
Israel's military said it will assist in
the evacuation of babies from gaza's
northern hospitals but those who live in
Gaza say there is no safe place Mike
Armstrong has our top story
tonight this is where it was supposed to
be safer Israeli Defense Forces have for
more than a week urged Gins to move
South the Border Town of Rafa is as far
south as they can
go the IDF says Rockets are still being
fired by Hamas into Israel and it hits
targets when it sees them Witnesses say
this was the aftermath of an air strike
one some don't understand
[Music]
this man says his aunt and cousin were
killed they weren't involved in anything
he says there was no resistance in their
house well The Exodus out of the North
continues the IDF paused fighting midday
in central Gaza opening once again two
corridors through the middle of the
strip tens of thousands again moved
South leaving behind everything except
what they could
carry Khalil a says he's been through
three conflicts in his lifetime but
never like this as he walks he says the
road is full of suffering and there's
been death all
around medical facilities are struggling
the World Health Organization says half
of the hospitals in Gaza have shut down
and the ones that are still open are
doing so with severely reduced Staffing
under worsening
conditions this is video from the AL
cuds Hospital in Gaza City shared by the
red crescent Society it appears to show
power to the building out and Medical
Teams working on patients by flashlight
about 2 and2 kilomet away the alifa
hospital a doctor says it's operating at
about 30% capacity most of the staff has
left the ones that stayed he says have
already decided their dead it's more of
a war zone here it's continuous bment
for more than uh like 24 hours
now the IDF is calling reports the alifa
hospital is under siege
lies this spokesman says there has been
fighting around it but that there's no
shooting at it and that the east side is
still open for people to
leave now there was smoke in the Skies
over Northern Israel tensions with
Lebanon
continued the leader of Hezbollah said
Saturday his forces will continue
engaging their as he put it sworn
enemy well Israel's defense minister met
troops near the border with leban and
had a warning for his Northern neighbor
he said Hezbollah is making mistakes and
could drag Lebanon into a war adding
what Israel is doing right now in Gaza
it could do to Beirut Donna Mike
Armstrong in Jerusalem tonight thanks
Mike in London more than 300,000 people
have taken part in a pro Palestinian
rally the largest of its kind there
since October 7th what do we want where
do we want
it protesters filled what would usually
be quiet streets on armus Day in the UK
showing support for Palestinians and
demanding an end to hostilities in Gaza
it was predominantly peaceful though
police did arrest nearly 100 farri
counter-protesters to stop them
ambushing the main rally and late
tonight police said they detained a
breakaway group of around 150 people
from the pro Palestinian
demonstration Russia's war on Ukraine is
still raging Ukraine says its capital
has been hit by the first Russian Air
Attack in nearly 2 months a ballistic
missile was reportedly shot down as it
approached keev no one was injured but
that strike was part of a Russian
bombardment overnight Ukrainian
authorities say they shot down 19 of 31
Russian drones and that four people were
killed that war and the conflict in the
Middle East is a reminder this
Remembrance Day of the terrible toll of
War at the national Remembrance Day
ceremony in Ottawa thousands of people
gathered to reflect and pay tribute to
those who have given their lives in the
service of their country McKenzie gray
reports a show of respect and admiration
for decades of service Canadians of all
ages braving the brisk Ottawa Breeze to
honor those who fought for Canada I
think it's good to be here to thank you
to the people who sacrificed their lives
for our
country those sacrifices still weigh on
Korean War veteran Sheridan Patterson
who never misses is a Remembrance Day
ceremony it's been a a habit with the
family for years I think it has to do
with the
uh with the uh people that we left in in
Korea 70 years after the end of that war
Patterson is only one of 9,000 Canadian
veterans still left who fought in either
Korea or the second world war and his
service inspired his son to follow in
his footsteps from the time I was a
little kid that's that's what I knew I
wanted to do I came home when I was uh
17 I'd graduated high school and I said
um joining up but those Traditions
dwindling today with the Canadian Armed
Forces facing major recruitment issues I
am very very concerned about our lack of
our our Readiness State we have um much
to do to get our Readiness back to where
it needs to
be those challenges not stopping
Corporal Bennett Alvarez from serving
after coming to Canada in 2006 it's a
type of giving back to Canada because we
were just immigrated from the
Philippines Armed Forces members past
and
present honored in both official
languages when we look at our
veterans we are looking at the very best
of Canada and a recognition of
indigenous veterans in ojip
come in go in gety win the proceedings
closing with hundreds of poppies being
placed on the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier today I'm thinking about the
victory of good over evil of light over
darkness and of memory against
[Music]
forgetting memories of sacrifice that
Canadians will never forget McKenzie
gray Global News
Ottawa at the going down of the Sun and
in the morning we will remember
them another ceremony took place in
Ottawa this morning at the national
Aboriginal veterans Monument it honors
the thousands of Inu matei and First
Nations veterans who served in war and
on peacekeeping missions for decades
indigenous veterans were not shown
respect or given recognition after they
returned home indigenous people weren't
allowed to parade on uh Remembrance Day
Services uh before I believe
1995 they always been in a sense um
forgotten or pushed aside uh so the fact
that we are having this ceremony here in
the nation's capital uh is significant
the national Aboriginal veterans
Monument was unveiled in 2001 it was
designed by indigenous sculptor and
painter Lloyd pan whose father served in
the second world war plans are in motion
for another military tribute in Ottawa a
monument to Canada's mission in Afghan
anistan the federal government though is
under Fire for the way it awarded the
contract to build it David aen explains
why the federal government knows where
it wants to build the National Monument
to the mission in Afghanistan and uh
it's right here this is a place called
The Breton Flats in Ottawa and it's
right beside the Canadian Mo Museum it's
on the banks of the Ottawa River and as
you can see it's just west of Parliament
Hill the question at hand though is what
to build here five design n proposals
were submitted a jury of experts was
chosen to pick a winner and they picked
this one from a group based out of
Montreal known as team da we take this
very very seriously and the site is
exceptional so we do we do think that as
a
team uh we have a civic duty Associated
to that but the veterans affairs
minister of the day Lawrence mccaulay
then changed the rules and said the
government would rely on a survey of 12
,000 Canadians including 3,000 who
served in Afghanistan and that survey
found the more popular design was this
one from Team Stimson its lead designer
was Adrien Stimson an indigenous veteran
and artist from Sika first nation in
Alberta so the government told team da
that while its design was the pick of
the expert jury the government would be
going with Team Stimson team da was
outraged you created a major breach of
contract and wasted public funds this is
a dangerous precedent for public art and
architecture in Canada and future and
all three opposition parties are upset
too the issues mostly about the process
so the government for the first time in
history in history they did not respect
the choice of the the jury as for the
current veterans affairs minister she
said the government simply wanted to be
sure it respected the wishes of veterans
it was very clear that the majority of
individuals who had responded to the
survey have indicated that the concept
the Stimson design was the concept that
they appreciated the most and we'll be
moving forward with that concept that
explanation failed to satisfy its
critics but it still may be years before
the monument fills up this empty space
here at lebreton Flats in fact the
government says it may not be complete
until
2027 and remember it was Prime Minister
Steven Harper that committed Canada to
building this monument and he made that
commitment in
2014 David aen Global News Ottawa
there's something in the water in Maui
coming up the pond reminding people of
Barbie or maybe Pepto
Bismol there is something weird going on
with this pond in Hawaii it is turned
bubble gum pink it's a coastal salt
marsh on Maui and Fish and Wildlife
staff say its salt content surged during
a drought allowing they think a single
cell organism called Hall bacteria to
thrive the pond has been like this for
about 10 days and people who live nearby
say they've never seen it like this
before an Ontario man who lost his wife
and daughter in the tragedy of Ukraine
Airlines flight 752 is speaking out to
global news about the threat he faces
hammed esun says he can't escape the
Iranian regime even in Canada this
summer he was reportedly the target of
public threats made by a man visiting
Canada as a tourist that man is a former
senior minister in the Iranian
government as [__] Mosa explains that
incident has raised some troubling
questions about Canada's
security you might not recognize this
man in the background of a news report
on Quebec tourism this past summer but
the Iranian diaspora did his name is
Sayad Hassan Kazi zad hashimi he's a
former Iranian senior Minister
reportedly vacationing in Canada he was
part of the same Administration
responsible for shooting down Ukraine
Airlines flight 752 in January of 201 20
dozens of Canadians were killed
including hammed ISM yun's wife and
9-year-old daughter it was outrageous
for the whole Community isun couldn't
believe it and called out the Canadian
government he was not an ordinary person
you see that he had a photo with Hassan
nasah the leader of Hezbollah which is a
terrorist organization in this country
in response to is yun's calls to have
him deported the former Minister
reportedly fired back with a threat he
was quoted in this Iranian magazine
saying I will retaliate against the
treachery of the foreign media outlets
and hammed esm Yun made me angry
actually that why he's here and he
threatens everybody he wants in late
August Canada's immigration Minister
tweeted that hashim's application for
temporary residence was denied and that
he was being barred for 3 years due to
quote Iran's disregard for human rights
it's just a slap in the face of the
community here this BC immigration
lawyer has spent a lot of time
documenting what he says is the huge
number of Iranian regime officials and
their Associates who are in Canada we
have about 700 names right now um that
are either have temporary residents
permanent residents or citizenship that
are in Canada and that are somehow
regime Affiliates we still counting so
it's going to be closer to a thousand
isun labeled as an enemy of the Islamic
Republic is always watching his back not
able to escape the regime he thought he
could leave behind even in Canada this
time Republic's agents are everywhere in
this country everywhere nari Global
News you can get a fuller picture of how
far the Islamic regime's influence
extends into Canada on a special episode
of the new reality tonight at 7: on
global still ahead a Canadian veterans
mission to protect the health of
Canada's
troops in Calgary 3500 crosses are set
up along Memorial Drive every November
honoring fallen soldiers from Southern
Alberta we're back in a
[Music]
moment as Canadians Mark Remembrance Day
it's also important to remember some
veterans are dealing with long-term
health problems during Canada's mission
in Afghanistan something called burn
pits were common they they were used to
burn waste including toxic chemicals and
the fumes those fires released have been
linked to a number of cancers and severe
respiratory illnesses as Mercedes
Stevenson explains the US government
recognizes the problem but Canada has
yet to do so Donna I spoke with retired
Master Corporal arjin greywall he did
six tours of Afghanistan and was a
member of the Canadian Special
Operations forces his mission now is to
get the Canadian government to recognize
the dangerous Legacy of tox burn pits
for our troops take a listen what is a
burn pit it's a it's a large bonfire if
you will that is in the middle of a
military base or a forward operating
base um and it's used to get rid of um
incinerate everything uh and I mean
everything uh helicopter carcasses
batteries human waste um ammunition um
food waste and what it does and why it's
so dangerous and why burn pits are such
a specific cause of toxic exposure um is
because it smolders it it doesn't
incinerate at a high rate it's not
plasma fired and it doesn't get rid of
anything very fast um and with the
populations that exist on military bases
they're often living around where those
um burn pits are placed um and and one
thing that's important to note is that a
burn pit is a bit of a necessary evil um
in these areas where we are unsupported
and we are AER locations um proper waste
facilities are not available um and can
be a security risk do you have any sense
that the Canadian government for
Veterans Affairs Canada is looking into
something similar I I honestly have very
little sense in it because I've done the
research and we've reached out to a
number of leaders within uh vac uh and
the calf to to try and understand the uh
the problem and what's being done about
it um my my my myself and my colleagues
are are recent veterans we we retired
only 3 to four years ago um so we know
exactly what it was then um and to see
that not much has changed uh is is quite
apparent this convers ation comes more
than a year after the US passed their
own law to extend Healthcare benefits
for veterans exposed to toxic burn pits
a reminder for our viewers Canadian
troops fought alongside our us allies in
Afghanistan and were frequently on the
same spaces in the same military basis
where those toxic burn pits were present
Donna all right Mercedes thanks and you
can hear more about this tomorrow
morning on the west block right here on
global next Canadian Forces deployed
overseas reflect on this Remembrance
Day this is today's Remembrance Day
ceremony in Vancouver's Victory Square
it is the city's oldest Remembrance Day
service dating back to
1924 we're back in a
moment as we Mark rembrance day here in
Canada there are over 2,800 Canadian
Armed Forces members on deployment in
various parts of the world including
about 270 who took part in a mission in
the Indo Pacific region our nitu Garo
was recently in Japan and she spoke to
some of them about what they are focused
on this Remembrance Day you know you
train and you train and it's nice to
Finly have an opportunity to get outside
and go do the job for real Sergeant
Nathan aonso says this is his first
overseas deployment he's on a mission
for operation neon enforcing sanctions
against North Korea my father joined the
Canadian Air Force back in 1982 and he
served as a aircraft mechanic uh until
2004 in the skies above the yellow and
East China Seas he and other Canadian
Armed Forces members reflect on the
service of those who came before them
those that we've lost through
peacekeeping those that we've lost in
wars in Afghanistan first second world
war Korea um and it's a real privilege
for me to serve and I want to thank you
and all Canadians and all military
families for their support this year at
Remembrance Day I've been doing in
uniform Remembrance Day Ceremonies for
uh well over 40 years and and it's
always interesting every year uh on
Remembrance Day I think about my service
I think about the people I've served
with in Afghanistan and in other places
some of whom aren't with us anymore um
but it's also a time to reflect on
people like my great-grandfather who
fought in uh World War I to remember
that at a time when I'm deployed abroad
and Canadian and serving with young
Canadians young Canadians like Corporal
Michael douly who's back at the military
base in Japan it's a very important
Mission it's du's job to ensure the
aircraft can communicate with the team
on the ground I'm kind of um the man in
charge of uh making sure everyone on the
ground has their uh the ability to talk
to the plane world it's uh conducting
its missions I'm just really proud to be
able to represent Canada on a on a
multinational stage like this coming
from a military background I have
generations and generations of uh family
members who were in the military it's a
lot of Pride honoring the sacrifice of
veterans while serving Nara Global
News and that is global national for
this Saturday November 11th I'm Donna
freezen this day means so much to so
many and we'll say goodbye tonight with
some moments from this morning's
National Remembrance Day ceremony in the
nation's capital thanks for
watching St the to the fr
[Music]
the
p